- Un deuxième vol habité réussi
pour l'entreprise Blue Origin.
À son bord, quatre passagers,
dont l'icône de la science-
fiction, le Canadien
William Shatner, alias
capitaine James T. Kirk.
À 90 ans, c'est la personne
la plus âgée à s'être rendue
dans l'espace.
Il s'agit d'un vol très court :
100 km d'altitude,
10 minutes au total,
dont quatre en apesanteur,
et un atterrissage en douceur.
À l'arrivée, William Shatner
était fébrile et heureux.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
du tourisme spatial,
entièrement automatisé,
que des civils avec un minimum
d'entraînement et la promesse
d'un voyage sans problème,
mais à grand frais.
OLIVIER HERNANDEZ, directeur,
planétarium Rio Tinto Alcan
- C'est toute la problématique
en fait du tourisme spatial,
qui va créer en fait différentes
classes et qui va permettre
aux plus riches, aux plus aisés
d'aller dans l'espace.
- Les futurs touristes
ont maintenant le choix :
à 575 km de la Terre,
trois jours avec SpaceX
pour 200 millions de dollars;
à 100 km, Virgin Galactic
ou Blue Origin pour une fraction
du prixet ; en 2024, le monde
vu d'un ballon stratosphérique
pour presque une bouchée
de pain.
Le tourisme spatial a aussi
un prix environnemental élevé.
En septembre dernier,
par exemple, le long week-end
de quatre touristes de SpaceX
autour de la Terre a coûté cher
à la planète.
ROBERT LAMONTAGNE,
astrophysicien
- Chacun d'entre eux, en volant
dans l'espace, a généré autant
d'impacts environnementaux que
85 traversées de l'Atlantique
en avion. Alors ça,
c'était pour un seul vol.
- Ouh! What a flight!
- Pour l'instant, il n'existe
aucune réglementation encadrant
le tourisme spatial, la
fréquence des vols commerciaux
ni leur impact sur l'atmosphère
terrestre.
- And the capsule touchdown...
- Fort probablement qu'il va
falloir se pencher là-dessus
dans un contexte où ça va
devenir de plus en plus commun,
un peu à la manière où
on réglemente le trafic aérien,
finalement
- L'espace, ça appartient
à tout le monde, pas juste
aux gens les plus riches.
C'est notre patrimoine céleste
et il faut en prendre soin.
(thème musical de "Star Trek")
- Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Cana